[Música]
ah
y
cuántos de ustedes recuerdan que estaban
haciendo en la tarde del 29 de marzo del
ese día esa tarde comenzó el peor
desastre natural de la historia de esta
ciudad comodoro rivadavia acá en el
corazón de la patagonia
estoy seguro que todos ustedes aún
tienen en la memoria esas imágenes y
esas experiencias que les tocó vivir a
partir de esa tarde difícil donde las
calles por las que transitamos
diariamente en esta ciudad se
transformaron en ríos de barro que
arrastraban todo lo que encontraban a su
paso desde los cerros hacia el mar
esa tarde en la que muchos de nuestros
amigos nuestros familiares nuestros
vecinos en la ciudad tuvieron que
abandonar sus casas porque ya no podían
evitar que empezara entrar el agua
esa tarde en la que muchos estaban
recogiendo a sus chicos en los colegios
de la ciudad donde se empezaba a formar
el tráfico habitual de cada día y donde
de golpe apareció el caos nunca en la
historia de esta ciudad cayó tanta agua
en tan poco tiempo
el agua la lluvia no dio una tregua de
algunos días nada más pero en tan solo
nueve días un segundo temporal volvió a
ser destructivo volvió a enterrar esta
vez en barro a muchas de las casas de la
ciudad y
nuevamente causó una gran cantidad de
evacuados y de situaciones de angustia y
de muchísima impotencia que es lo que
sentimos en aquel momento todos nosotros
yo me dedico a la planificación al
desarrollo urbano y regional desde hace
muchos años trabajando para el banco
interamericano de desarrollo o fui parte
de un equipo que implementó una
metodología de planificación urbana en
más de 50 ciudades en 26 países de
américa latina y el caribe
este es un desafío urgente para toda
nuestra región porque 7 de cada 10
habitantes en este continente habitan en
ciudades
uno de los aspectos principales de
nuestro trabajo
en esta iniciativa fue a ayudar a las
ciudades a planificar mejor su
crecimiento pero también a prepararse
mejor frente a los eventos
traumáticos que genera la naturaleza y
los desastres naturales como los
incendios los terremotos las
inundaciones
el cambio climático a nivel global hace
que estos eventos se produzcan cada vez
más frecuentemente y que tengan cada vez
mayor intensidad
pero a mí no me tocó vivir la ciudad lo
que pasó en la ciudad no me tocó vivir
la inundación el temporal con un experto
urbano me tocó vivir como un habitante
más como todos ustedes
y lo que sí me dio fue una apreciación
distinta quizás más profunda de todos
los problemas y todas las crisis que
existían en esta ciudad antes de que
ocurra el temporal
extrema desigualdad social
y un escaso respeto por la naturaleza
problemas de ordenamiento del territorio
de como nosotros nos organizamos y qué
hacemos con el uso de la tierra
y hacemos con la movilidad
y un modelo de desarrollo que no genera
desarrollo un modelo de crecimiento que
genera riqueza pero que no nos genera
desarrollo en la ciudad
lo que me dio también haber estado acá
en ese momento habitando esta querida
ciudad
puede ser parte de la mayor experiencia
de solidaridad que probablemente haya
existido en la historia de como
la crisis fue tan profunda tan
inesperada que todos nosotros tuvimos
que aprender a ayudarnos y estoy seguro
que cada uno de ustedes encontró la
manera de ayudar al que lo necesitaba
en todos los barrios aparecieron estos
héroes que primero ayudaron a que no se
pierdan más vidas de las que se
perdieron pero ayudaron a recuperarse
que lo más difícil cuando el agua baja
con el barro se va ahí estuvieron los
vecinos estuvieron los amigos haciendo y
ayudando en todo lo que se podía
en aquel momento yo me preguntaba desde
entonces es algo que resuena en mi
cabeza como una ciudad después de vivir
un evento como este tan traumático que
nos cambia para siempre a nosotros y nos
cambia como ciudad cómo podemos
aprovecharlo positivamente cómo lo
transformamos
a ese evento en una oportunidad
y en el mundo hay ciudades que lo han
hecho
hay ciudades que han logrado pasar de
una situación difícil y que quizás una
crisis muy profunda les ha ayudado a
cambiar y hacer aún mejores que antes de
que ocurra
yo les quiero hablar de tres ciudades
que son buenos ejemplos pero esto nos
podría hablar de muchas otras
la primera es una ciudad que nosotros
hoy la asociamos a todo todo el
atractivo que tienen las ciudades
europeas una ciudad dinámica vibrante
interesante para conocer con mucha vida
cultural pero sin embargo hace muy poco
tiempo la ciudad de bilbao en el país
vasco' vivía una profunda crisis
económica una crisis donde su
monocultivo industrial su industria del
acero se encontraba en decadencia donde
el 30 por ciento de la población no
tenía trabajo no tenía expectativas
y en el medio de ese contexto después de
muchos años a partir de la década del 70
donde la ciudad entro en un declive cada
vez más pronunciado ocurre la peor
inundación de su historia en mil 983
donde el río después de una semana de
lluvias se desborda la ría como le dicen
ellos se desborda y llega a avanzar
hasta el nivel del agua hasta los
primeros pisos de la ciudad un río que
por las industrias estaba contaminado
con lo cual no sólo destruye comercios
hogares y vidas sino que también deja un
nivel de contaminación altísimo en toda
la ciudad
una ciudad que está casi a la misma
latitud que nosotros pero del otro lado
del océano pacifico llamada christchurch
en la segunda ciudad de nueva zelanda
también se encontraba en una situación
económica difícil con la necesidad de
reinventarse las industrias o las
actividades comerciales o económicas que
le habían dado le habían ayudado a
crecer ya no tenían el mismo dinamismo
y en ese momento de su historia en 2011
en febrero ocurre una de las réplicas de
uno de los terremotos que había ocurrido
hace unos meses mucho más fuerte pero
esta réplica tuvo epicentro
prácticamente debajo de la ciudad a un
nivel muy cerca de la superficie y fue
tremendamente destructiva
prácticamente el centro histórico de la
ciudad quedó completamente desgastado
185 perdieron a 185 personas perdieron
sus vidas y muchísimas más miles
perdieron sus hogares
la tercera ciudad que enfrentó una
crisis de las que quiero comentarles es
medellín
las crisis a veces no las provoca la
naturaleza muchas veces las provocamos
las personas
[Música]
en el caso de medellín en una situación
también de una economía muy difícil de
una profunda desigualdad social de una
concentración extrema de la riqueza de
una ausencia del estado
y de un altísimo desempleo aparece el
narcotráfico en los años 80
la primera imagen que nos viene a la
cabeza lamentablemente cuando pensamos
en medellín
la epidemia de violencia urbana que
surgió a partir de ese momento llegó a
su pico en el año 2009 91 donde murieron
por homicidios más de 6.800 personas se
la conoció a medellín en ese momento
como la ciudad más violenta del mundo
con la capital de los homicidios
estas tres ciudades
tuvieran
la capacidad de ver puede aprovechar su
momento más difícil el momento en que
tocaron fondo para reinventarse
decidieron ser distintas y ser mejores
yo quiero hablarles sobre eso
y no porque crea que hay recetas que
podamos aplicar
de un lugar a otro no creo que esas
fórmulas que hace sirvieron a una ciudad
que nos vayan a servir acá en comodoro
pero si desde que pienso en estas cosas
de que ocurrió la inundación
trato de analizar cuáles son las cosas
que esas ciudades todas estas que les
mencioné hay muchas otras tuvieron en
común elementos alguien común en una
ciudad que aprovecha su peor momento
para ser mejor que antes
les decía no no creo que sea una fórmula
lo que nos puede dar este análisis los
que nos tiene que dar son ideas para
tener las conversaciones que nos están
faltando en la ciudad para tener los
diálogos constructivos de hacia dónde
queremos ir
los tres elementos que yo quiero
destacar y quiero conversar con ustedes
son fundamentalmente la planificación la
innovación y la participación
conceptos que quizás suenen abstractos
pero cuando lo vemos como sirvieron para
que estas ciudades puedan despegar de
una situación difícil nos sirven para
repensar algunas cosas en primer lugar
decía la planificación y la
planificación es básicamente saber hacia
dónde queremos ir la planificación es no
improvisar
saber hacia dónde queremos ir es tener
una visión de futuro una visión que nos
inspira y que nos permite estructurar un
plan o una hoja de ruta para alcanzarla
y en el momento esto puede ir cambiando
no es un proceso que es un check eso es
algo para cumplir es algo que nos
permite a nosotros tener una hoja de
ruta concreta clara para empezar a
avanzar hacia dónde queremos ir quizás
éste es el principal aprendizaje de
bilbao
bilbao como les comentaba era una ciudad
que tenía una serie de dificultades y
que en su
activo principal que es la ría
se encontraban
las industrias los astilleros los todos
los equipamientos portuarios
que tenía además su ría completamente
contaminada por lo que desechaba la
ciudad y las industrias
y que sin embargo pudo crear una visión
colectiva de hacia donde querían ir y el
eje central de esa visión tenía que ver
con recuperar la ría para las personas
con generar espacios públicos de calidad
con hacer que esa ciudad sea atractiva
para que todos todos los jóvenes la
ciudad no elijan irse a buscar un futuro
distinto futuro mejor en otro lado sino
también atraer a las personas talentosas
que aquí si quisieran aprovechar y vivir
ahí en esa ciudad
el icono quizás de esta transformación
tan tremenda y tan profunda que
experimento bilbao es el museo
guggenheim
pero ese museo no hubiera sido tan
exitoso si no hubiera habido una visión
una planificación que le diera sentido
muchas ciudades quisieron evitarlas
creando un museo no fueron exitosas
porque les faltó esa visión estratégica
esa capacidad de estructurar toda una
ciudad y un atractivo y un desarrollo
orientado a hacer una ciudad de
servicios una ciudad del conocimiento
una ciudad emprendedora
el segundo elemento que yo quería
destacar es la capacidad de innovación
las ciudades también pueden ser
innovadoras
innovar implica fundamentalmente tener
el coraje de tomar decisiones difíciles
de cambiar lo que no nos gusta y
arriesgarnos a equivocarnos no hay
innovación sin la posibilidad del error
me decían lo hizo me decían y aquí vemos
el metrocable del teleférico es quizás
el símbolo mayor que tiene la
transformación de la ciudad parecía una
una locura pensar que el teleférico
podía ser un transporte público sin
embargo el principal desafío que tenía
medellín era integrar a los barrios
vulnerables que vivían en las zonas
altas de la ciudad con el resto de la
ciudad no sólo se lo plantearon como
ideas sino que se propusieron que lo
iban a hacer lo hicieron lo financiaron
y hoy es una solución efectiva como lo
son también por ejemplo escaleras
mecánicas
en el espacio público que permiten
conectar y ahorrar muchos minutos y
horas de viaje a las poblaciones más
humildes que vivían en las zonas altas
de la ciudad
y por último la planifica la
planificación y la innovación son
actividades interactivas actividades que
no tienen sentido sin la interacción de
las personas
por eso el tercer elemento que yo quiero
destacar es la participación la
participación pone en el centro de todos
estos procesos a las personas en el caso
de la ciudad de nueva zelanda lo primero
que hicieron cuando tuvieron que empezar
a planificar cómo resurgir cómo
reconstruir su centro urbano que había
sido completamente destruido e
inutilizable lo primero que hicieron
decía fue escuchar a las personas
crearon esta iniciativa que se llamó
comparte tu idea
decenas de miles de personas de todas
las edades tuvieron en cuenta a los
chicos por supuesto muchas veces esto se
olvida pero es fundamental pensar en
todas las en todas las visiones posibles
todos tienen algo para aportar a la
construcción colectiva de la ciudad
ellos comenzaron por preguntarle a las
personas y a partir de ahí estructurar
una planificación una idea de ciudad
que tuve que tenía una visión de ser una
ciudad más verde más sostenible de lo
que eran antes más preparadas para hacer
frente a los desastres naturales y que
pusiera en el centro a las personas una
ciudad de escala humana
en medellín
la participación está en cada uno de los
logros que ha alcanzado la ciudad
existen espacios donde la participación
es efectiva no solo en la planificación
sino en la gestión en el diseño de las
políticas públicas y en la evaluación de
qué tan efectivas han sido esas
políticas públicas
y hay un elemento que muchas veces se
olvida cuando se habla del caso exitoso
de medellín y es la identidad que tienen
los paisas los habitantes de esa región
el orgullo por su región el cariño por
su ciudad
el respeto y el amor por sus tradiciones
por sus valores por su historia porque
esa es la base que nos permite a
nosotros participar de algo ser parte de
algo más importante que nosotros mismos
la experiencia nos demuestra que ni los
incendios ni las inundaciones y los
terremotos ni siquiera las guerras y las
armas nucleares como en hiroshima pueden
destruir una ciudad porque la ciudad no
son los edificios la ciudad somos las
personas que hacemos que una ciudad
exista y tenga sentido
cuando las personas creen
que el cambio es posible
cuando las personas tienen confianza en
esa construcción colectiva entonces el
cambio es posible
y como nosotros descubrimos en el peor
momento de nuestra historia que podíamos
ser un equipo que podíamos salir
adelante
este es el momento para construir a
partir de esa solidaridad de esa
tenacidad que tuvimos en el peor momento
construir una ciudad mejor
hagamos que el 29 de marzo de 2017 sea
el día en que comenzó la reconstrucción
de comodoro el día que empezamos a hacer
que comodoro sea una ciudad mejor es
posible
[Música]
ah
o no